- What's up, DailyVee?
Obviously trying and
continuing to innovate
and doing some fun stuff.
What you're about to see
is a merged DailyVee, Dallas and Atlanta,
two talks, double the fun,
three talks, that's right,
I did two in Dallas,
thank you DRock,
you'll probably see DRock.
Well actually, you're
behind the camera, right?
- [DRock] Yeah.
- You won't see DRock which
is just how I like it.
Hope you enjoy this.
You've got your perspective.
I just want to be happy.
Don't you want to be happy?
Hello.
How are you sir?
- Do you prefer your left
ear or your right ear?
- My right ear, please.
We're in Dallas, Texas.
We're here at the
National Radio Conference,
but their term radio is being
used loosely at this event,
podcasting, voice, AI,
I genuinely think the
ears are the next game
and I've been talking
about that for awhile.
As a matter of fact, we're
recording this in video
and I'm not so sold
that more people won't consume
this through just audio
than in video form.
So I'm excited to be here.
It is a--
- Turn your head that way.
- You got it.
It is a classic.
Thank you so much,
it's a classic audience.
I think the far majority
of people here are
from the hardcore radio industry
and so the challenge here is how do you,
a lot of industries are in
genuine, genuine trouble
if they don't have a hard pivot.
This industry has to take a soft pivot
because the macro thesis is gonna be okay.
As a matter of fact,
they're about to go into a golden era.
However, if they become romantic
about how that content
is being distributed,
they can become quite vulnerable
and not as successful.
If they're romantic that
it has to be done in Sirius
or on 77 a.m. and not
as a skill or a briefing
on Alexa or Google Home,
or not as a podcast,
or not as video being filmed
while that radio show is going on,
then they will lose.
Winning's better than losing.
I'm gonna try to land,
thank you so much--
- Are you comfortable?
- Phenomenal.
- Can you count to 10 for me?
- 10, nine, eight, seven, six,
five, four, three, two, one.
- One more time.
- One, two, three, four, five, six, seven,
nine, 10, no eight.
- You good?
- I'm good.
- One more time.
- A, B, C, D, E, F, G, H,
I, J, K, L, M, N, O, P.
Thank you.
Winning is better than losing.
- Your team, by the way, is fabulous.
- Thank you.
- And they're very protective
of you in a good way.
- Thank you.
I think finding the right balance
of what you just said is,
we have so much empathy, gratitude
towards any partner we work with
while they'll know whatever we need to do
from a time standpoint
or things of that nat,
we're hedging.
- Are you Mets or Yankees?
- This is funny,
so I'm a diehard sports fan.
Like the fact that you brought up the fan
just made me smile in my heart.
- Well, you should come over.
No, you should come over and see Boomer
and all those guys, Mike.
- Love all those guys.
Grew up a humongous four sports fan,
was born in the Soviet Union,
grew up in Jersey,
so had a real mix.
So I was a Jets, Yankees,
Rangers, Knicks fan
but the Rangers and Yankees
I literally stopped watching completely
the day they one the
championships in '94 and '96.
- Really?
- I like completely
miss the Yankees dynasty
because I got '96, Charlie
Haze catches the ball,
and I literally do not
watch another Yankees game.
- No way.
- It's the wildest thing.
I'm now--
- Please don't turn your back on radio
because it means so much to the fans--
- Do you know how historically
on board with radio
I've been over the last decade?
- I know you have.
- I believe in audio more--
- Because I know you always talk about it
in your presentations.
- My number one thing here is gonna be
as long as you're not overly emotional
in the pipes that distribute it,
you will be unbelievably fine,
you will actually go
into the next golden era.
If you are disproportionately
vested in the actual pipes
and are caught in that,
you need to start creating the other pipes
because if you put your head
in the sand on the pipes,
you will get destroyed.
That's the truth.
There's no reason that most
of the companies in there
that have not started,
whether it's Alexa,
whether it's podcasting,
whether it's something else,
why let some other entrepreneur
come along and take that?
- Oh, you're dead right.
Well, listen, I'm gonna let you go
but do me a favor,
if you ever want to,
I'll reach out to you
and if you want to stop
by and get with those guys
that would be great.
- I'm happy to do it.
Awesome, take care.
All right, bye bye.
- [Female] Before we get started
with the program this morning,
I'd like to introduce the
chief marketing officer,
(audience applause)
- [Female] Thank all of you
for being here early this morning.
- [Female] Hold onto your hats
because I am sure he
is not gonna hold back.
So please join me in welcoming
Gary Vaynerchuk to the stage.
(audience applause)
- Thank you, that was very sweet.
Any business here that digs in its heels
and thinks the traditional
distribution of radio
is going to win out the
game in the next decade
is going to lose.
The internet will continue
to eat up market share,
it will happen.
And when it happens,
the important part is to
make sure you are diverse,
if you're in the distribution business,
across building briefings and skills,
across the voice devices
that will dominate
the homes and the behavior and the offices
and the cars of all of our consumers
and podcasts will continue to grow
and people listening to
audio through video products
will continue to grow.
And if you happen to be in
the content business in here,
well, get ready to get rich
because if you have the best
content over this half century,
it's going to work out.
It's as simple as that.
The art is now winning the
business leverage game,
not the pipes
because the pipe came along
that changed the course of the industry.
It's called the internet.
We continue, from me down, in this room,
to wildly underestimate the internet.
Let me remind you of how young
the platform actually is.
The consumer web,
not the nerd stuff that the
military and academia was doing.
The consumer web is a 1994,
1996, 1998 phenomenon.
We are just getting started
and the indicators are in the water.
The one thing I don't
understand is macroeconomics.
What I can tell you
is that if Jeff Bezos is the CEO of Amazon
and the macroeconomy is in a good place,
it's the layup of all time
because he's 100% consumer-centric
and playing for his legacy
which means his behavior
will play out well long term.
99% of Fortune 500 companies
are run by executives
who care about what
the stock price will be
when she or he retires six months later
so they can strike and buy a yacht.
Those companies lose.
So that's my stock tip.
- Gary, thank you.
- Thank you, thank you.
Thank you.
Thank you so much.
Thank you, thanks for saying that.
I'm so happy to be here with you guys.
- That was amazing.
- Thank you my friend,
thank you for saying that.
Thank you.
Who's taking this?
Who should I give this to?
How are you?
(laughs)
- [Male] Thank you guys for
being here, appreciate it.
In the (mumbles) scene,
like to wear tee shirts on stage.
I hope that's acceptable for you guys.
(guitar music)
- Thank you.
- You're welcome.
Thank you so much.
- May I take my picture with you?
You are one of my most--
- Woop, I got you.
- My gosh, you are the reason
why I don't give a shit
what people think about anymore.
Thank you.
- You're welcome so much.
Thank you for saying--
- It took years of therapy
and you.
- I'm glad you did it.
Thank you.
- Thank you.
- Gary, would you take a picture with me?
- Yes, I will.
- I'm a fan.
You changed my life too
because I say what I think
and it made me go up in the ratings.
- That makes me happy.
- Thank you so much.
Keep doing what you're doing.
- I will, take care.
- [Female] That was great.
Thank you so much.
- Thank you for saying that.
You're welcome.
- Totally enjoyed meeting you.
- Thank you so much, thank you for that.
Take care.
Made sense, right?
- Just gonna give you a quick thank you.
I got my first job by citing
your book in my interview
and they were very impressed
that I knew who you were
and what I was doing.
- That means a lot to me.
Thank you.
- Big fan and love to get a picture
and I have some questions
but I'm not even gonna--
- Fire one away while we're doing this.
- What would you say about
people who work in those goliaths
who are trying to get the advantage
and just aren't being heard?
- Put it on the table respectfully
so you don't get fired
but you're historically correct
so that when people leave
or when things get bad,
they're like, wait a
minute, Roy was right,
let's make him a VP at this new thing.
You're not gonna change a goliath
but the people that don't
die on their own sword,
don't move up either.
So if you believe it, say it.
No different than what
you did to get the job.
- Absolutely.
Thank you.
- Take care, Roy.
- Thank you so much.
- You're welcome, take care guys.
Bye bye.
Thank you, thank you.
- Gary, I want to ask you a question.
My biggest concern on everything I'm doing
is experimenting with the content
and the reason why is
there's just so much to do
and so many things can happen.
- But that's a good thing.
It'd be way worse if
there was nothing to do.
Don't get crippled by opportunity.
Don't judge yourself.
That's what will help.
- [DRock] You want to intro the podcast?
- Yeah, so what you're
about to listen to is,
are we going here?
- [DRock] Yeah.
- Yeah, okay.
- All right, so I think you just changed
the definition for radio
for this audience today
in a big way.
What do we need to do as an industry
to change the definition of radio
for advertisers and agencies?
- I think one, if we're not
romantic about the word radio,
then we can get into a
conversation of voice content
delivering value to the end consumer
and we need to, for brands and businesses,
make them think of us as that,
not as the thing they grew up with
that is on the dial of
their car or in their home.
And so the networks need
to make themselves 360
and not just be at the
mercy of one distribution.
They need to be in the podcast business,
they need to be in the
audio skills business,
they need to be in the video business.
Every single radio show in America
should be filming it
and putting each episode on YouTube
and Facebook and Linked In today.
- Many of them are.
- Many are, many/most aren't.
99% are not.
- Or people aren't aware that it's there.
- Or they don't think they have to.
They subconsciously even,
forget about consciously,
they subconsciously get into
a romantic point of view
of like, this we'll be okay.
We've always been around, we'll be okay.
Audio is more than okay.
I actually think audio's biggest era
probably since radios hit the scene
is on the verge of being here.
It's the way that audio
is being distributed
that I think needs to have
a thoughtful conversation.
- [Interviewer] So can we
talk about audio content
for a second
and what makes it incredibly relevant
and engaging for consumers?
And there's a part two to this,
so radio in the former definition, right,
is a collection of
incredibly powerful brands.
And those brands employ
incredibly powerful human beings
that create content in life vocal.
- And those brands are at the mercy
of the casting of those human beings
no different than a sports
team or a company, right?
Keep going.
- [Interviewer] So what do they need to do
to continue to remain
relevant and engaging
in this new audio content world?
- Who?
- [Interviewer] The radio station brands.
- Let's start there, let's start there.
If you're a radio station brand,
if you're Z100 in its
apex in 1993, 1998, 2000,
whatever the apex is,
if you didn't start building brand
on the internet in 2000
and definitely in this audio explosion,
if Z100, I'm just gonna use
it 'cause I grew up in Jersey,
if Z100 is not a relevant
player in podcast land,
if Z100 doesn't have a very thoughtful
voice-activated device strategy
of how it's gonna show up uniquely
on Alexa or Google Home or
Apple Pod or whatever else,
if Z100 is not putting out its video clips
on Facebook, YouTube, Instagram, TikTok,
and if Z100 is not a
podcast brand that matters,
Z100 is vulnerable.
- [Interviewer] Right,
Z100 has to be Gary Vee.
- 100%, and it's funny you say this,
this is my biggest point,
and you know you're watching it manifest,
I'm living it,
I am building brand
at a speed and at a scale that is unusual
and if you've taken to account
that I am not on a television
show, it's unparalleled,
and it is completely based on this thesis
which makes it fun for me to talk
because I'm not hypothesizing here,
I'm living it.
- [Interviewer] Right, right.
So you're in audiophile, right?
- I believe in audio the most
because I, like every
human that's watching me
and listening right now
is now a creature of 2020
and wants to do multiple things.
We're amazed by our kid's ability
to be on the iPad, the
iPhone and watch TV.
We did it too.
You watched MTV while you
were on a two-way phone call
with your friend
and going through a teeny bop magazine.
You multitasked too,
that's what humans do.
- Radio matters because
- Radio matters because it is
one of the distribution tools
for audio content
and audio content is massively
on the rise in our society
because humans want to
multitask in a 2020 world.
- And radio works because, same answer?
- Radio works when the
audio content is consumed
and the creative coming
out of the human's mouth
influences the person on the other side
to do the transaction
that the company wants,
whether that's to buy a sneaker
or go to a concert.
Audio, much like what I'm doing right now,
is a form of communication
that has the ability
to change one's mind,
and that's always powerful.
But because I roll the way I roll,
the conversation is not audio.
The conversation is
you're using the literal
interpretation of radio,
you may be using it under the context
of all distribution, you may,
most people do it, you may, I
don't know, and that's fine,
honestly I have no vested interest
or even passion one way or the other.
But I would not want to
be a linear network today.
I do not want to be CBS, NBC
and ABC in 2020 selling Empire.
I want to be an OTT or YouTube.
That's just the reality of
what consumers are doing.
And this is historic,
by the way, everybody's
listening or watching,
go do your history lesson
of what happened when the radio came out
to the newspaper industry
or when the television came
out to the radio industry
or when cable came to the 13 channels
or when the internet came to cable
or when the OTT, this is just forever,
this will be forever.
People used to do smoke signals on melons.
That's how we talked.
People used to draw in caves.
That was real.
That was how we sold.
Things change and we
need to change with them.
Pictures and video and words and audio,
that will never change,
that's how we communicate.
Where we communicate it and
in what distribution form
is constantly changing.
Some things get 50 years,
some things get three minutes.
The internet's gonna get a long time.
MySpace didn't have the longest time.
Vine didn't have the longest time.
TikTok may or may not.
It may be Facebook and
YouTube, it may not.
But at the moment,
if you want to sell something
to a 15-year-old in America,
TikTok is the place you
need to put your energy.
That's just real life.
- [Interviewer] That's it.
Thank you.
Thank you so much for being here.
Okay.
- Awesome.
- Thank you.
- That was a great talk today.
Really enjoyed it.
- Thank you, thank you.
- [Female] Long time Jets fan too.
- Love that.
You got it bro.
Awesome, take care.
- [Male] Few more.
Ready?
- Yep, you got it.
Really nice to meet you, take care, sir.
Bye guys, bye everyone.
Bye guys, bye guys, take care, take care.
Thank you.
- That was awesome.
That was awesome.
Maybe I should get a podcast.
- I think that really
resonated with the room.
I couldn't push you
guys harder to do that.
- I'm doing what I can
but it's way above my detail.
- [Male] The problem in this industry
is people are so romantically
attached to radio.
- The end, that's it, that's it.
People dig in, that's why people lose.
People dig in.
They dig in on something,
they don't even realize
why they're digging in.
They're digging in because
nostalgia is a very powerful
part of our framework.
- Change is uncomfortable.
- It's gonna take me time.
I'm gonna do it, where do you live?
Oh, I know it very well.
I do so much garage saleing in New Jersey
so I know like every,
and I did a lot of direct mail.
- But I'm a Giant fan so--
- I understand.
I think--
- [DRock] That was a really good keynote.
- [Gary] Yeah, it really was.
- [DRock] That was really, really good.
- [Gary] Yeah it was.
I nailed the ending.
- [DRock] Yeah.
The lion thing was great.
Intro for the podcast.
- Hey guys, what you're about
to listen to is a really,
it's really funny, I'm
doing this intro right now
just after DRock and I spoke for a minute
of like how good that one felt,
speaking to the radio and audio industry.
I'm always at, kind of quote, unquote,
I think I'm at my best
when I'm at a conference
where that industry's timing
is at a crossroads
where if they give up on romance
and focus on their ability
to actually leverage
what they're doing right now
an not allow new incumbent distributors
of the energy,
whether that's retail or media,
they can win.
And I feel very obligated when I speak
to bring the most value
and I feel I brought a lot of value today
this morning here in Dallas.
I hope you enjoy this podcast.
- People say to me, they're like,
what is the greatest piece of
advice you've ever received?
And I say it was that moment
when I was at my low.
Do you remember that?
- I remember it like yesterday.
Of course I remember it.
- I say Gary looked at me
and he said, stop focusing
on the shit that you suck at
and double down on your strengths
and I fucking did it.
- I'm aware, brother,
I'm so happy for you.
Oh man, it makes me so happy.
- Can I get quick shot?
- 100%.
Yeah, I'm excited to give my talk.
Thank you, I got it down.
Take care, guys.
- [DRock] Want to give me
content of where we are?
- We're at the LinkedIn thing.
- [Male] If you want to go on stage,
this is the minute.
Otherwise, I will take
you through the back
and we'll do a walk out.
- [Gary] It's gonna be a lot of people.
- [Male] It's 4,500.
- I love it, nice.
- [Male] So it's a big group.
Back here and then you're on
stage 3:45 and you're done.
- [Gary] I'm very happy, thank you.
And DRock, what happens then?
I go back to the hotel, right?
- [DRock] No, we don't go back.
- [Gary] Are you sure?
'Cause I thought we did.
- Bro, it's your boy here
at Dream Motivates, OMG.
- YVEE, what up?
- There go DRock.
- Yeah, DRock's real too,
he's real too.
- Yo, Dream Motivates
let me tell you something
about Gary man,
if you're not following
him, you need to follow,
you done lost your mind.
He done written books,
he is awesome motivator
and he doesn't like being
called motivational speaker.
However, he is a very good
business man and you got to.
Like he share some knowledge
like some fourth quarter living.
- Listen, it comes down to this,
we got one at-bat,
nobody's come back from the dead,
you can't prove it,
you got one at-bat
and I don't understand why
people living their lives
based on other people's opinions.
Your mama, your boss,
a comment in Instagram,
focus on you, like offense.
- That is so amazing.
Let me just kind of tell you,
I'm tripping right now,
like I'm trembling.
- You also smell good, by
the way, on the record.
- Have to smell good and
look good, matter of fact.
Yeah, and I been looking
at the garage sale joint,
I've been looking at the flipping,
I looking at all your posts,
I've seen the growth,
I've seen you at the Jets game.
I listen, let me tell you,
ask me a question, I'll
tell you about yourself.
That's how much I follow you.
- I'm humbled.
- I'm a kid from the hood,
never had nothing,
I started my marketing firm
just me trying to get it,
trying to grind,
trying to get an opportunity.
I began, I call it the Heisman.
You know the Heisman, you
go people pushing you off
instead of bringing you in
and I'm trying to get the
opportunity to get in.
- Listen, right now I'm
taking some heat from people
about free work is a good idea
and people are like, oh,
that's bad, you're mean
and I'm like you're saying
that from a place of privilege.
People come up and when
people are Heismanning,
one of the ways to break
that stipple arm is like
oh, you don't think I can do it,
let me do it for free for a week,
let me do it free for a year.
People don't get it,
when the door's not open,
free is the fucking key.
- Yes, yes, and because you
gotta show people your worth.
- People are like when you don't do that
you're not valuing your worth
but the reality is you need context,
and by the way, if you say,
hey, Gary Vee, I'll do it for you for free
or hey, Mikey, I'll do
it for free or DRock,
or LinkedIn, you can stop at any moment.
You can stop the first day after free
if you're like, oh wait
a minute, DRock's a dick.
- No, you know how monumental you are?
No, I'm not trying to get you,
but what I'm saying is
I've been an entrepreneur, right,
you like made an entrepreneur like a verb,
you like made it cool,
you made it swagger
and you say it all the time
but you give away so much game.
- That's where I was going--
- You give away game
and you know that hopefully
the reciprocity'll come.
- Because you know what's funny?
It's not hopefully the reciprocity comes,
it's that what I'm feeling
right now, admiration,
is more interesting to me
than an extra zero in my bank account.
It's not complicated.
It's not super complicated.
I know that most people
don't talk about it
but it's not complicated.
Some people like admiration
and legacy more than money.
- I remember you said something,
I was like, man, I never
thought about that.
You's like, you know what I want to do?
I want to have the biggest funeral ever.
- Yeah, I do.
- And that's a part of admiration like
who are you, who were you
and if you pass away, like
you said you gonna die,
if you pass away and it's
four crickets and your mom--
- If you go into the
ground with $12 million
and four people at your
funeral, you fucking lost.
- And that shook me.
That means like every person I see,
I want to smile,
they might be having a bad day,
hey, let me tell you, like
you smell good, like you did,
like you're having a good,
and I'm just saying listen,
the Bible says,
and I know you have your religion
but you have not 'cause you ask not,
I will come in if you need
some footwork in Dallas
or come out there to New York,
I will literally come to the spot,
I'll fly out there tomorrow--
- I'm gonna have you
DRock collect right now
'cause I gotta go to this room,
I want to say hello to a lot of people
bu that's done, live your life, yours.
- Yo and can I get a
tag, a Dream Motivates,
can we push it out there a little bit?
- 100%.
Keep listening to Dream Motivates
'cause he smells good.
- Shout out to my man
Gary Vee and the bird.
- I got 75,000 fans
want to know, all Gen Z'ers,
they love you,
they want to know why you like Gen Z.
If you could hold on,
I got Gary Vee in the house,
why do you like Gen Z?
- I like Gen Z because they're
gonna be around the longest
from all the other
generations that are here,
it's 'cause I like people.
The kids are always right.
People just don't know it at first.
- Agreed, agreed.
I need a tag saying listen to these guys
to learn more about Gen Z.
- Hey guys, it's Gary Vee,
listen to these guys
to learn more about Gen Z.
- Thanks dude.
- You're welcome.
- Hello Gary Vee, how are you?
Big fan of you.
- Thank you, thanks for having the books.
- Yes.
- Bro, I'm glad we ran into each other.
You'll get his email?
- [Male] I'm shaking right now.
- You're amazing, I always
love watching your videos
on Instagram, LinkedIn.
- Thank you, thank you so much.
What's your name?
Lily, nice to meet you.
Yes, hi.
Hi, how are you?
How are you?
- I work at LinkedIn.
I'm a hustling musician
on the side as well.
Love all your stuff.
- Awesome.
- Thank you.
- Hey, love what you do--
- For you guys,
the stuff I say is what I believe.
I think it's a game of patience.
I think where youngsters get caught
is you don't realize how little time
the next five years actually is
but then you stress it.
- Five years is two years
is what we're saying now.
- People are worrying about two weeks.
- Right, you're right, you're right.
That's how I got into judgment.
The real reason you're worried about that
is 'cause you actually care
what other people think.
And so people are just living their lives
based on other people.
And that's always a bad idea.
- And you can't.
- It's called defense.
By nature, it's called defense.
You know what I mean?
So nice meeting you.
- I need one more shout out.
It didn't go,
so listen to these guys for Gen Z.
- Yo, listen to these
guys for Gen Z, 2009.
- So in this room, as we said,
represents people from (mumbles) agencies,
RPO agencies in the world
and the industry as a whole is evolving.
Recruitment marketing, AKA content,
is one of the fastest growing
aspects of this industry.
- Makes sense.
- And I think a lot of
the questions that I hear
are about just where to start
'cause these are businesses
that haven't traditionally
needed to think about marketing strategy,
a content strategy, a brand strategy.
- Well, this is super funny
and obviously some people
here know me or consume me.
I've been screaming for the
last year about LinkedIn.
I'm telling people that
sell fitness equipment
and raisins and socks to do
content marketing on LInkedIn.
You can imagine what I think
you should be doing on it.
If you are not producing four
to 12 pieces of content a day
at the scale of your businesses here
and probably even closer to 25
on LinkedIn a day organically,
you're making a fundamental mistake.
And there's nobody here even
remotely close to doing that.
I believe that to be true.
- [Female] Challenge accepted, Gary.
- I really believe it, you know?
I'm glad and I hope you do
because I think what you
may know based on jumping in
or some of you may know,
following my career the last 10 years,
I end up being right
about this stuff a lot.
Here's why, I'm not guessing,
this is happening right now.
The organic reach in
LinkedIn content right now
is far more reminiscent
to 2011 and '12 Facebook
than anything I've seen.
I would think that you're probably aware
that there was a golden era
of Facebook organic marketing
that you heard about from
your friends or you lived
or know if its existence.
It is happening right now
in your face in LinkedIn
which is the biggest permission
for B2B people on Earth ever
in the last 20 years
to get a good deal
and yet A, people aren't acting on it
because B, they are not consumer-centric.
You will not produce content
that brings value to the
companies you're trying to serve
or the people,
you will make content that is
allegiant to your business.
And that's why it won't succeed
and that's why the content
won't resonate as much.
So it's not only recognizing the strategy
but it's understanding
how to make the creative
that actually brings
value to the other person
and being disciplined enough
to being able to do that.
There's no secret of how
to get into better shape.
Eat better, work out
but many people can't keep the regimen
for a million different reasons.
My strategies are basic,
it's not super complicated.
This is execution.
- [Male] I have a quick one.
So when you're talking about
reinvesting into your company,
do you ever have an idea or recommendation
that you give to
companies in terms of like
how much percent of revenue
they should be reinvesting into marketing?
- No, my answer is as
much as humanly possible.
I believe that the internet
will commoditize everything except brand.
As much as humanly possible.
Communication's the only thing left.
The product itself,
obviously, if your candy bar sucks,
I'll just speed up everyone
knowing it sucks, the product
and your brand
because everything in
the middle is in trouble.
Bookstores went first,
limos and cars went next,
the entire macro infrastructure
of physical retail
is happening right now.
Wait till you see what happens
to the fast food and fast casual space
with all these cloud kitchens
and everyone's ordering everything
and getting food delivered in one minute
on brands that don't have stores
but it's the new McDonald's.
It hasn't even started.
You guys have felt the effects.
There's been technology
or things of that nature
and there'll be more.
I would never,
it's very rare for us to consider
to hire an outside recruiting firm
because I'm just gonna
analyze people in the wild.
The data's there.
Wait till that becomes consolidated.
Wait till people understand
that is a very good way to do it.
You better build a brand
because it is reputation.
It's why people say all those things.
They're right until they're not
and how you build your reputation
and the scale in which you can
and what's happening,
what's gonna happen and has
already happened to some of you
and you know this to be true,
is you see, this is a
ridiculously big spider.
(audience laughs)
What's gonna happen
is somebody who's only been in
the business for three years
is gonna start winning business from you
and you're gonna be complaining
that they have no
experience and what the hell
but they've already struck
the heart and the mind
of the person that decided
because they've watched
four videos on LinkedIn
and they made sense to them
and they're very thrilled
that you've been doing this for 26 years
but Karen made sense to them a week ago.
Don't let that happen.
Like I said earlier today
in a different conference,
which has been a fun day, two talks,
which is rare for me,
Goliath should never lose to David.
If you have a big company,
which I assume at some level you do here,
or influence or what have you,
you should not be losing to upstarts.
None of those wine stores
should've lost to me.
They just didn't believe
in email and Google.
They thought catalogs were better.
Thank you.
- Great topic.
(audience applause)
- We'll pot it up for you, okay?
- Understood.
- Great.
- [DRock] You know where we're at?
- We're at some humongous LinkedIn event.
There's like 6,000 people out there,
4,500 to 6,000 he said.
- [DRock] You get it?
- It's a solid number.
I'm feeling it, DRock.
- [DRock] What are you feeling?
- Something.
- The energy?
(upbeat music)
- I'm going live in
like six, seven minutes
at this keynote
so if you're catching this right now,
check it out.
What's this hair?
Swipe up.
(upbeat music)
DRock, what have you learned today?
- Care about your employees.
- You didn't know that before?
- No, I learned it again.
I mean you're saying the same
shit over and over and over.
- But I say it in different ways.
- Very different ways.
- In different context.
- Yes, so I learned--
- Distributed differently.
- On different platforms.
- With different analogies and nuances
and sometimes a word that changes it
in a way that finally
makes someone see it.
- Like today.
- Or the person's just ready to see it.
- Yeah, sometimes it takes little bit of
you need to hear it in a
different way sometimes
or you need to hear it multiple ways
and then one day--
- Or something might've happened today
that made you actually
hear it differently.
- Correct.
- 6,000, 5,000.
- I dropped my gum.
- You did
and I stole your gum.
I just stole this out of your hands.
I don't think the camera caught it.
Oh and that one.
All right here.
This incredible moment to be,
and I love this moment
because in seven years I
won't be as underrated,
like I'll have to like
what's that TV show,
like the secret fucking singers,
what is this show that's huge right now,
the masked, the masked?
No where they're like in
costumes and they're singing.
- [Male] Oh, I have no idea.
- You know what I'm talking about.
I feel like I'm gonna do that in 20 years
when I feel like oh,
I'm gonna get like a,
what's that movie with Travolta
or like fucking Nicolas Cage?
I'm literally gonna win it,
the whole fucking thing,
and then rip my face off
and come back as a different human
and win it again,
to be like see, it wasn't luck.
- [DRock] You're gonna
need a voice change.
- That's fine, that'll be easy.
That's easier than ripping
your fucking face off.
- [Male] Go.
(upbeat music)
(audience applause)
- [Gary] Pursue her dreams.
She can always go back to school.
You're welcome.
- [Female] Gary, can I get a picture?
- Hey Gary.
- Yes sir.
- From one diehard Jets
fan to another
- was that you clapping?
I saw you, bro, I saw you, bro.
- When you gonna buy the team?
Can't come soon enough.
- [Gary] I need 20 years
bro but you're young,
you'll get there.
Hey, hi guys.
- You have to wish my
husband a happy birthday.
- [Gary] You got it, what's his name?
- I want to tell you something real quick.
- Go ahead.
- 10 years ago you told me
to be the best recruiter
I could ever be, right,
and I just want to tell you (mumbles)
I fucking love you brother.
- I love you back, bro.
- Can I get a selfie?
- Yeah.
- Ah, selfie.
Thanks man.
- [Female] Love your
content, Gary, I really do.
- I appreciate that, I got you.
- Oh, thank you.
Thanks so much.
- Can you say hi to my husband Eli?
He loves the Jets.
- Eli, what up, bro?
O and three, don't
worry, we're coming back.
- All right, thanks.
- Thank you, bye guys.
Whew.
(upbeat music)
(DRock mumbling)
- Yeah, some guy Brandon
on Twitter's like,
bro, why'd you interrupt
Tilman Fertitta so much?
You were interviewing a billionaire.
Don't give a fuck.
Whether I'm being sweet
or being interruptive
or being competitive or
being kind or doing business
or doing friendship,
I don't give a fuck
about how much money you
have in your bank account.
It's the fucking
stupidest shit of all time
judging somebody based on that
or really the stupidest thing of all time
and I hate using stupid,
a very bad idea
is treating people different
because of their status
or financial framework.
Actually, I just got motivated.
I'm sending a text.
Yo, good morning,
I just got fired up
so I'm sending you this text.
Here's the tip of the fucking day,
treating somebody different
because of their financial status
or their cultural status
or how many followers they have,
thinking that you treat
people with privilege
even if they earned it,
even if they fucking
earned every part of it,
treating somebody different
is a huge mistake.
I don't think I have that
much time on the text.
No, I don't.
Yo, yo, I just got super fired up.
Somebody said something on Twitter
that triggered me.
Good morning, what's up, tip of the day,
treating somebody differently
because they have money
or fame is ludicrous,
is ludicrous, treat
everybody the same, fuck.
(DRock mumbles off camera)
- 9/24 4D's intro.
Yo, what up, guys?
Another in depth, is this for the podcast?
- [DRock] Yeah.
- For the podcast,
what's up, podcast?
Hope your run's going well,
hope your dog pooped
and you guys are heading
back to the house.
I hope you had a good day at work
and driving in the car
and there's not too much traffic.
4D's insight from September 24th,
people are learning like
fucking crazy from this,
I hope you enjoy it.
You should sign up for a 4D's.
It is absolutely the Sasha
Group, thesashagroup.com,
VaynerX's agency for small businesses.
It is absolutely the number one thing
we sell in the world
that is most loved.
Anyway, nonetheless,
here's an insight
to one of the hours I
spent with people at 4D's,
which is one of their 12 hours that day.
(DRock mumbling off camera)
- It's fucking huge.
This conference and then I'm out.
If you haven't checked
out my text platform,
212-931-5731, text me sucka.
- [Male] What's up Gary?
- [Gary] How are you, bro?
Good to see you.
- [Male] Got to kick it with your brother,
the test we took last year in DC.
- That's what's up, that's what's up.
Thank you for saying that.
Almost got destroyed by salad.
I'm gonna try to do more
of that kind of stuff,
just fun stuff.
Just I think that, yeah.
You know like even the part with AJ.
- [DRock] Why I'm not coming
out of debt bit (mumbles)
so I'm trying to (mumbles).
- That makes a ton of sense.
Like even if you have the camera down,
like sometimes it might just be funny.
'Bout to go speak for
these lawyers in Atlanta,
'bout building their brand
and not just trying to get
SEO and print and outdoor
television and radio as a funnel,
little bit more native to this.
Same mindset as always,
pretty just like chill or focused.
Usually DRock and I are talking
one second before I go on stage
or I'll be like give me two minutes
and I'll think about the first
line and then I'm off or,
but it's super easy for me to go up there.
I'm just completely and utterly focused
on how do I bring the most value
to the people in the room?
I know they're lawyers
and I know it's 20 fucking 19.
I got the rest.
- [DRock] you never brought up
(mumbles) before.
- Once in a blue moon just to
like right before when they're like,
Gary Vaynerchuk helped
build his father's business
and I'm back stage and I'm just like
okay these are jewelry store owners,
let me make this comp
to my dad's liquor store
or sometimes I'll do that.
Yesterday I did it,
in an HR conference, I said,
I thought about how
funny it was that my dad,
not to his fault, but Russian style,
big thing was the
employees are the enemies
or watch out for them to steal,
that was running through my mind,
that's how I started it.
But other times I'm like,
okay, make sure you
tell them about TikTok,
first thing, be like I
made a lawyer TikTok video
and I come out and I'm
like Atlanta, what's good?
And then I'm gone and I lost the whole,
so it goes both ways.
- [Male] Please welcome Gary Vaynerchuk.
(audience applause)
(upbeat music)
- Let me make it perfectly clear
before we get into Q&A.
I have 0.0% interest in you doing anything
that I talk about this morning.
You're not my mother,
you're not my brother.
I genuinely don't give a fuck about you.
(audience laughs)
I am doing this keynote
because it's being filmed
and I want to be historically correct
and I will reair it in eight years
when I'm talking about something else
and if you follow me on Instagram,
I've quite enjoyed the last year
of pulling up my videos
from eight and nine
and seven and 12 years ago
because I'm looking to
build my reputation.
If you want to go back home
and do exactly what you're doing,
I actually am happy about that
because the less money that
you put into these systems
is making that attention
a better deal for me.
So so there's no confusion,
I'd prefer you don't do anything
I'm talking about this morning.
And the good news for me
for doing this for the last decade
is I know that 98% of you will not.
I will do a nice job here
for the next 44 minutes,
we will get fired up,
a lot of things are
gonna make sense to you
in its mix of cursing and comedy,
I will answer very direct questions
that show you I have deep
practitionership in this,
this isn't fucking college up here.
This is every day real life.
I've built two businesses from scratch,
one from scratch, excuse me,
to a $200 million business
over the last nine years,
in revenue, profitable, not valuation.
(audience laughs)
I built a three million dollar business
doing $300,000 in gross profit
before expenses with no credit line
and no venture back money
to a $60 million business
in five years as a 22-year-old.
I'm Mariano Rivera,
and if you don't know what that means,
Mariano Rivera is a hall of fame pitcher
that just retired and went
to the hall of fame recently,
played for the New York Yankees,
he was an extremely good pitcher.
He was their closer for two decades
but ultimately, if you're hardcore
baseball knowledgeable
fan, he had one pitch.
He had one pitch that literally
not one human being besides Edgar Martinez
knew how to hit.
And that's me.
I suck at a lot of things.
The one thing I don't suck at
is understanding what
the consumer is doing
at this second.
I understand human behavior
and I understand human attention
and I understand that not
like buying a mutual fund,
I understand it like day trading.
I know exactly what's happening
right this second on LinkedIn, on TikTok,
on Facebook, on Twitter, on YouTube,
in print magazines, on
the radio, in billboards,
on TV, on Netflix, period, end of story
and that currency is going to be
the single most important
thing in perpetuity
because as the internet
continues to evolve,
everything in the middle is commoditized.
The amount of people that give a shit
of what college you went to
or how many years of experience you have
is staggeringly low.
Knowing who you are
is super duper important.
- [Female] Who are you looking for?
- I'm gonna miss my
flight if I don't bag out.
- Hello, come on in.
- Thanks for being here.
- One word, communicate.
- But it's a consumer-centric
selfless communication structure
not a how do I see it selfish
communication structure.
And so it's simple.
It's inherently not human.
Most people are deeply
insecure and selfish,
thus everything manifests from that.
- Give to give, don't give to get.
- But you have to have it seen.
You could be the sweetest
fucking pumpkin pie of all time,
if nobody knows it exists,
you're fucking finished.
And even scarier, people
are invested in things
that seem to be working,
'cause they're used to it,
and they're watching it
decline by five or seven
or 13 or nine or 11% each year
and it becomes defense, right?
While not recognizing your direct mail
is just not as good of
deal as it used to be.
It's that.
And then it's Google,
and by the way, and then
it's not doing it right.
There's plenty of people in there
that spend $5,000 on Facebook
and had nothing happen
and then they just give up.
It doesn't mean that Facebook's broken.
So there's a lot of,
you're absolutely right,
and it's in simplicity,
but in the nuance I just ranted on,
that's where the action is
because I'm not special.
You clearly understand the thesis.
It's the filter and the
execution underneath it
that is very nuanced.
- Do you have to get someone in house to,
'cause you're never gonna go,
when you go oh, we're
gonna spend 30,000 a month
with this agency to help us
with our Facebook stuff, right?
- I think in a small scale
in house is a great way to go, I do.
You can steal somebody,
my belief is that everybody
I'm looking at right now
should take the at-bat to try
to figure it out themselves
because it's that important.
That was the point I made
about balancing your checkbook.
To me, communications is oxygen,
no different than actually understanding
how to handle cash flow.
I really believe that.
I believe it's become that
in singularly important.
I really believe that.
- [Male] I think in our industry too
we're so built up to be for trial,
you're so versed in what you're doing
but to actually be
vulnerable to who you are
finding that voice I think
is the hardest thing.
- I understand that,
I understand that
and honestly I think it
makes a ton of sense.
- [Male] You got to say
fuck it and do it, right?
- I mean listen, I know how,
when I hit the business scene
outside of the wine scene,
I remember just being very comfortable,
thank God, again, good
parenting, good circumstances,
I felt comfortable being myself.
95% of the comments I got
in year one and two were
you don't dress the part and you curse,
no one will ever take you serious.
And I remember thinking
very early on, I'm like,
what naivety that results in the end
and the consumer will
always make the decision
and we value the things in the middle
'cause we're taught to,
school and many other things,
we value the middle,
and the middle is a commodity.
Everybody's doing the middle.
- [Male] Gary, I think a lot about--
- Do you guys want to get food
and I'll set up a chair there?
Everyone'll sit and we'll just
go right hardcore into it.
Let's do it.
Shhh, I'm gonna try to
maximize value here.
So I've got to go to the other
room and then catch a flight.
So in the next 15 minutes or so,
I'd love to do more Q&A.
I'd love people to get very
specific about their questions
and I appreciate you being here
and I hope you enjoyed
the talk this morning.
Let's fire away.
Sir?
- [Male] You're the man dude.
- Can we close the door?
- [Male] How much importance
and time do you put on,
is it a byproduct, you just do a lot
and you naturally learn from it
or you consciously focus
the things you are learning
as you are doing?
- Yes.
- [Male] What's the give and take though?
- Fully that.
- [Male] All the second?
- I spend 100% of my time
on watching people react to things,
not to the actual thing.
- [Male] You outsource the output?
- 100%, but I also, and
what DRock would tell you is
my copy skills, I know what people want
because I'm listening first.
For all my talking
and all my interrupting
the question and all this,
I'm listening at all times,
thus, I have a better sense,
I just know what resonates because I'm so,
and don't forget, and you know this,
this is now fucking 37 years of,
this is talent.
I've had to come to realize,
I'm like oh right,
in business, in entrepreneurship
and communication,
no different than in
singing and in sports,
there is natural talent.
The reason I set up the conversation
around lemonade and baseball cards,
I've been doing this for so long,
it's why I was such an atrocious student.
It was so black and white to me,
that I couldn't even give,
I couldn't even pander to
societal norms of the '80s
to even appease my poor mother
who would punish me so
bad every report card
because I wanted that every
second in the classroom
to figure out why did they laugh
when I disrupted that,
why is everybody wearing those sneakers?
I literally just said
something that I've never said,
I know DRock's never heard this,
I used to sit in class
and fundamentally analyze
everything people wore
without even knowing why I was doing that.
And so that's it.
- [Male] But then how much of the time
is you spend with the audience building
versus thinking about how
you can monetize, a jab,
active to understanding though.
- I'm a little bit unusual,
and I think you know this,
I have a separate business that
doesn't monetize my audience
thus I spend no time,
my great secret compared to
all the other personalities
is none of the important finances come--
- [Male] How much time do you spend
thinking about the monetization?
- Zero, zero, because the
framework's already been created.
- [Male] The audience is there
and then you think about it
in different context though.
- I just know there's some trickle down
but zero thought into it.
It's just not the way I think.
I build other businesses
to make sure I don't have to rely
on any conversion from my,
you can ask DRock,
when we sell a tee shirt for fun to learn,
like I'll do on my text messaging platform
or if it's the sneakers or the wine,
I weirdly like better
when it doesn't do well.
- [Male] But it does
monetize the audience.
It's unconscious for you,
but you have people in place
to actually translate it?
- Yes, yes, but again,
the economics are so minute in comparison.
Yes, but really that fucking matters.
That changes the entire intent paradigm.
- [Male] All right Gary,
so everybody's different in the room
and in that big room.
So I am a brand in Alabama,
we're the largest firm in--
- Like a Nick Saben-like brand?
- [Male] Like I'm the
second most recognized--
- Go ahead.
- [Male] He's not kidding Gary, at all.
- [Male] I believe you.
And so it's confusing to me when I say
that I have traditionally,
so I have 2,000 billboards,
I'm already aware of the second,
I'm already on the TV.
How do I transition?
- By taking 20 to 40% of that money
and putting it 100% into
something like Facebook
against your core demo,
45 to 90, that still translates there
and then by teaming up
with your team and others
to take five percent
and start the beginning
of that next generation,
which is not gonna come,
you are not gonna do well at first
or maybe even at all on Instagram at first
but it's just starting
to build the awareness.
But I promise you this sir,
and this is universal,
there is no radio and
billboard perfect execution
that trumps perfect Facebook execution
for who you're trying to reach.
Here's why, on common sense
that billboard is vanilla.
The fact that you can make a reference
to Jalen Hurts transferring to Oklahoma,
you could do all sorts of shit.
You could make 8,000 billboards
that matter to 8,000 different
psychographic and demographic,
Alabama's got a lot of
micro personalities,
gender, races, age groups.
You're gonna make a,
the Andy Warhol Super
Bowl commercial last year
that Burger King did
missed the mark
because nobody under 40
fucking knew what the fuck was going on.
When you sell vanilla,
vanilla's a popular flavor,
but when you sell vanilla,
you miss a lot of customers.
And what you're doing
is sheer penetration,
and you're no dummy,
billboards can't work as well
as they did 10 years ago.
Every passenger's looking
down at their phone.
I'd rather them see your pretty face.
I promised you Seth.
- This is your last question.
- I'll sneak in yours too, Digger.
- [Male] Sorry.
- I failed all my classes
'cause I do not listen to authority.
- [Male] If you were my marketing guy
and you were in charge
and I gave you $100,000
or $200,000 a month,
to put into social media,
how would you spend it?
- I would run Facebook and LinkedIn ads
and make contextual creative
to the data that shows me
who the historic customers
you tend to get are
and I would run the ads
against those demographics
and psychographics
and I would make 43
different pieces of video
starring you or somebody else,
that went to bring them value
so that we built awareness.
- [Male] So those ads would not look
like my traditional TV ads?
- Are you fucking crazy?
Do you know how bad your
traditional TV ad is
no matter how awesome you are?
- [Digger] You scared me
with the voice recognition.
How do we stay ahead of that curve?
- By building a brand, Digger.
They're the only way,
if that gets to the scale that it could,
listen to the words,
if that gets to the scale
that it could in 15 years
the only thing that's left is brand.
They have to say Alexa,
can you get me Digger?
'Cause if they say give me a lawyer,
give me a whatever, a trainer,
a milkshake, whatever,
and that is gonna play out.
- [Digger] So can you
say that one more time?
- Sure.
- [Digger] Can you say
Alexa, give me Digger?
- Alexa, give me Digger.
You got it.
Yes ma'am, one more.
I gotta finish with ladies.
- [Female] So I love
my haters and I know--
- You love them because it motivates you
or you love them because
you're empathetic to them?
- [Female] Both and I think
it's just a little more traction.
They don't realize that
as they're posting things,
they're just getting us--
- So you're a believer that all
publicity is good publicity?
- [Female] They're opportunities.
- I think that's fair.
Go ahead.
- And I'm always trying to figure out
a good formula of when to
engage and when not to.
Sometimes it's nice when
a client engages for us.
If it's a bad--
- It's a great question.
- Wonderful.
But I haven't quite figured out
a good formula.
- There is no formula.
I actually think you've got it down
'cause I do the same,
I just think it comes down
to timing and serendipity.
Sometimes you just got 15 minutes
and you know you're,
when there's a lot of
things going bad around me,
I've got some fires,
I've got some issues,
my grandma passed away this
last summer and when she was,
life, the Jets are O
and three, I'm on tilt,
sometimes I'm not just in the mood
to know I'm gonna have to spend 15 minutes
maybe going back and forth to try to,
other times I'm bored, I feel fresh,
I got eight minutes 'cause
something got canceled,
I'm like I'm gonna get in there.
I wouldn't overjudge yourself,
there is no proper answer.
I think it's predicated
on your current mindset
to be able to be the bigger person.
People lose 'cause they go
into a debate or a conversation
but they're not emotionally balanced,
which allows them to get triggered,
which makes them overreact
which changes the context
of the actual merit of the conversation,
which fucks up the whole
thing, AKA America.
- [Female] Thank you.
- You're welcome.
- [Female] All right.
- [Gary] Thank you guys, thank you.
Thank you, so nice to meet you.
- That must be exhausting for you.
I'm apologizing for everybody here.
- You know what, it's hard,
it's hard to not be grateful.
No, no, no, it's actually quite easy,
believe it or not.
You know what I mean?
How could one be confused
at how nice it feels?
To take this for granted
would be ludicrous.
Take care.
Have a great day.
- Appreciate it.
Have a good flight, man.
Take care.
- DRock, he said this must be exhausting,
I said to be grateful and get confused
and take this for granted
would be ludicrous.
It was interesting.
- [Larry] Jets fan from '69.
- You're luckier than me.
You got to see it.
- I've never heard of you before.
- Well it's a pleasure to meet you.
- Today is the first day.
- I'm glad.
What's your name?
- Larry Kramer.
- Larry, real pleasure.
Thank you.
- [Larry] I wish there was
little bit more of the how-to
as opposed to the why.
- The how-to's super simple.
The how-to is Google.
- [Larry] Learn on Google,
you're talking about?
- Correct.
If you said how do I
post a video on YouTube,
how does a lawyer,
where are you based?
- [Larry] New York, Long Island.
- How does a lawyer in Long Island reach,
Google will answer it,
the How-to is the commodity.
People focus way too much on the how-to.
The how-to, you literally go to Google
and any question you can think of
that you would want to ask me right now
whether in written form,
in a free white paper or in video form,
depending on how you learn,
you will know how to
do it in three minutes.
That is the commodity my friend.
That is the commodity.
You can find that.
- And I was looking for social
media marketing people online
and it was very difficult to thread out,
I don't get that.
- Yeah, I think that it's so important
that you should spend three to five hours
Googling how-to, opening the accounts,
taking a photo, running
against people that live in
and making a video and saying,
if you've had an injury,
or I don't know, whatever you
think is right, and learn.
It is as important as running your PNL.
It has become that important.
I really believe that.
- I suffered through
that Monday night game
and the traffic.
Oh my God, that was horrible.
- Yes, that was tough.
- Nice to meet you.
- Take care, Larry.
How are you?
- Good, how are you?
Thank you so much.
- Take care.
- DRock, did you get that part too?
That was really good, the how-to.
- You speak Russian?
(speaking in Russian)
- I'm Michael's dad.
- I know the guy, the
guy, the fucking guy.
- [Female] What else do you need?
- Nothing, you've been amazing.
Thank you.
- [Female] Gary, a pleasure.
Thank you so much for being here.
- [Gary] Let's grab out bags.
- [Female] Yes.
(upbeat music)